Dude when I was in Oakland, first of all. So Oakland dude,
when I was in Oakland, I, for some reason,
I always thought that Oakland had so much graffiti in it.
I don't know why I thought that.
I don't know if I saw a movie or some or whatever,
but when I got to Oakland, everything was graffitied and yeah, I was like,
I was right. How did I know that I've never been in Oakland, got to Oakland,
saw everything that was spray painted in bubbly letters. Oh,
Clint is so gangster dude. Like the street,
like the side of Starbucks has colorful,
popping off letters and. It,
everything is graffitied. You park your car, you walk into a place,
you come back, your car got graffiti on the side of it.
And it just says Oakland zone with the Z Oakland zone
Oakland's own. Um, yeah, dude.
Um, so, so I went to Oakland,
there was so much graffiti did the show I was with my, I was with two openers.
Uh, the show is pretty good. The theaters beautiful dude.
I don't even know why that theater is so nice. It's so crazy.
When a theater Shona, that theater is so nice. It revamped Oakland.
There were like two blocks of Oakland that were like really nice.
And then the rest of it, you can get, so killed
two blocks to Oakland, beautiful. The rest of the blocks Oakland,
you can get so killed. But, um, so, um, no,
but Oakland is like, apparently the,
the place that they're like gentrifying next outside,
it's like the silver Lake of San Francisco. Um, but, uh,
so I did the show got back. It was really not much to do in Oakland,
at least on a Thursday night. Uh,
and so I,
so we went back then we tried to get, um,
a delivery for food, uh, from an app
and we got it and waited
for an hour, which is sometimes how long it takes. Understood.
Maybe Thursday night in Oakland is a busy time for the food app
service, uh,
called me 50 minutes in and said, Hey, sorry.
Uh, but the pizza place, you tried to get pizza from w ran out of dough,
50 minutes, 50 minutes in dude.
Now my level of rage through the roof,
call me in the beginning. You got them pizza place this way,
we diminish it. The fire rage. Okay. Breathe through.
It was starving. Still thought, you know what?
50 minutes in my life, not a big deal. So I'll order another one.
So ordered another one from a different pizza place. That looked way worse,
but it doesn't matter because I was just hungry at this point.
I need to fill my belly right. Ordered another place from a pizza place.
No called me 50 minutes later.
And the place ran out of ran out of dough.
Okay. So now that's two different pizza places that ran out of dough.
Now, Hey, this is where I say pizza place.
Don't run at a dough because that's how you make pizza.
And if you don't have dough, then you don't have pizza.
And if you don't have pizza, you're not a pizza place.
And for not a pizza place,
you're not making money any other way because your job is having a pizza place
and you need a job in this world. Okay?
So I ordered from a third pizza place, no. I waited an hour.
They called.
I called them and they said, and this is no.
We ran out of dough.
This is the third pizza place in Oakland that ran out of dough.
Now this is three hours in no dough, anywhere in Oakland.
I'm trying to get pizza. I can't get it.
So now I'm.
I can't be so I'm. So, you know, when you're hungry, everything is more angry.
And so I'm so angry. Now it's 3:00 AM. All right.
Now I say, these pizza places in Oakland. All right,
I'm going to go to a diner. I go on the app.
I look for a diner. The diner closes at four.
I look at how long it's going to take me to get this Turkey sandwich or whatever
the hell I get. It's going to take 35 minutes. Okay?
So now I order the from the app. It says,
it's coming at 35, 40, 50 minutes, whatever the it is, I call the diner.
I say, Hey diner, this is what happened.
I tried to get a thing from three different pizza places.
And it couldn't come through. Now. I know you come up, you close at four.
Cause I checked online, covered my bases, my babies.
So I looked so I called them and I said,
I just want to make sure that if the Postmates guy is late and gets there at
like four or five or whatever the
that you're not gonna not let them in. Okay.
And, and whatever. And the guy says, Oh no, we make the,
we make the food. That's no problem. We make the food. I said, okay,
we're going to make it right now. They make it right now. Okay.
The, the restaurant at 4:00 AM
cancels. My cancer's my order. Okay.
I've stayed up for hours to try and eat. I should have slept,
stayed up. Cause I saw hungry. All right.
Didn't now just cause I had to watch the purge movie during the whole
thing, the origin, the origin story of the purge, whatever the.
I'm a big purge movie fan. I love the purge movies. The SA the, the, the,
they did the three and then they did the one that was like supposed to be the
prequel. And that one was just, I liked them all.
And that one was just not that it wasn't that good. Sorry.
It's all good. But you know what you did, you know, you got damned.
Did you ever see a movie? And you're like, Hey guys, you know,
you got dad. It's all good.
I watched it cool 50, please. But you know,
you get them then watched a movie last night. We'll rename.
We'll re we'll remain nameless, but it was an Oscar nominated movie.
Hey, Hey dude, you know, he got him dead.
It was bad. It was bad.
All these, so many of these movies are bad, whatever, but it's all good.
They keep making them why even make a movie now just get a YouTube channel.
You know? Uh, I guess, I don't know. I,
so then I went to Las Vegas, all right. Went to Las Vegas.
Now when I went to Las Vegas, I got this, uh, I got this. Uh, Oh, by the way,
before I wrap this up, my whole point is Oakland.
Figure out your right dos situation, dude.
Figure out your dose situation. I'm a comedian.
When I go 30 minutes on stage. I don't,
I don't say well guys ran out of jokes. I do 30 more minutes of jokes.
You're a pizza place. Have dough, cheese and tomato sauce. And that's it.
That's it have that? I got jokes. Kay.
If I have jokes in Oakland and I'm S and I'm doing my,
have dough, pizza places.